bella tutti ragazzi e bene ride nessuno
video sono fa vj ci sono stati sua e
brand che è quel gioco dove si lancia il
pane praticamente ragazzi siamo davvero
rimasti che va un fatto questi quattro
livelli ci avevo messo una vita
praticamente ragazzi hanno fatto anche
il livello garage vanno aggiunte non
l'ho ancora fatto ragazzi quindi voglio
vedere che di che cosa si tratta anche
se sarà capolavoro videoludico sono
convinto ci siamo ragazzi comunque
andiamo avanti che mediche ma toast
perfetto non mi ricordo più neanche come
successo siamo ragazzi cioè sono in un
cassonetto ma serio e l'obiettivo è
quello di tostare sta roba senza
sporcarla e partiamo da dentro un
cassonetto ragazzi cioè mi sembra
giocavi ovviamente abbiamo fatto la gara
è stato è stato un parto solo uscire da
sta roba figuriamoci deve volare per
forza l'ho preso
cazzo mi sono incastrate è ovvio nel
cassonetto non ci sporchiamo ma qui si
certamente ce la fai a salire prima che
moriamo tutti di crepacuore si va bene
così come cazzo è possibile che non si
sporchi un sandwich si è buttato in un
cestino avere un fan non fa niente
ce l'ho fatta come faccia tosta rally è
la madonna ronaldinho versione pane
ragazzo infiammabile c'è quel caso li
crei credo che sia quella vado ma vado
una merda già faccio bravo cazzo rava
unico mio siamo riusciti a fare un
ottimo livello di partenza a parte
serova ragazzi era era un training e la
per ricordarsi un attimino le mosse no
perché se continua iniziavano subito ma
casca sta roba
no che figo oddio ragazzi è stata la
cosa più atroce della mia vita ma sono
vivo ragazze reame capperi in salsa
barbie dove devo andare riprendendo anno
a terzi mica rimbalza ce la potremmo
fare lega sarà difficile vaffanc on the
mist incastrando lega no ma non muoio
qui incastro grazie a dio ai bye bye bye
bye bye non riesco più a uscire i
ragazzi sentivo stare in galera la
stessa cosa ce la puoi fare niente
ragazzi sono morto sono impedimenti e
morire è la stessa cosa ne sono lui mi
sono anche ragazzi niente domanda niente
domande veloce veloce perché checco
zalone cascato dietro
dietro il frigo e verso nella vita di
riuscire a fare sto gioco è impossibile
cavo pagato qualcosa con questo sforzo
si no eva ma sei una testa di me mi si è
chiuso il ces tir i santi che scendono
mi è caduto il coperchio del cs ma vi
rendete conto
quando giocava ketty mario ero più
contento ma veramente è rimasto aperto
perché c'era lo stendino sono col cazzo
lavoro devi sono usciti prego dal
cestino esce ci sono dal cestino esci c
è bravo no
tieni aperto a piani aperto no mi ha
visto spezzandole camera c'è vela è uno
stupro è uno stupro di cestino 50
sfumature di parma ragazzo buttate ce la
farò dio mio santo cioè i ragazzi vera
ma parte disk è veramente non c'è verso
no no no no no no no no no no bravo
ho rischiato di morire merda non lo so
io ho rischiato di morire malissimo ma
ok piano dai forza accendi la luce
cos'è sì ci penso ci ha messo regalsemi
sembra liberamente di far partorire una
persona che sono io tra l'altro che è
stato la tracce sono salito solo su una
mensola poi non so neanche come si fare
questo se sta in culla ai i bicchieri di
vetro
[Musica]
mi fate fare un secondo il punto della
situazione che sono mezzo morto
grazie piatto quando vivo ingrossare la
prossima volta me lo chiedi primo ok
gravissimo
by zio vai no ce l'ha la merda sul muro
porca la merda niente ragazzi siamo
condannati a stare in questo cestino per
l'eternita duomo [ __ ]
vabbè non interessa se sto sfondando
tutto non sa cosa sta succedendo lega un
disastro gli sta inglobando lo stendino
dire adesso cosa che rob e propria casa
o mio dio nota hersman fly su ma poi ce
l'ho fatta
sono vivo se non vivo per miracolo
termino sta succedendo là verso vivo se
è stata la cosa più orribile dello sri
non so come ho fatto e serviva 3 per
cento
va beh non lo voglio neanche sapere ma
tanto morirà prima il primo moscerino
che becco perché son tipo morto però kay
ora vi supplico vi supplico bisogna sì
davvero deviati su ragazzi se muoio mi
cazzo se muoio mi incazzo non ci
prometti nella vita nella vita porca
[ __ ] [ __ ] ragazzi 4 per cento a non
ci credo non ci voglio che rende guarda
ti ringrazio dio 40 foto ultimi minuti
per salire su questo c'è una motosega sa
ci fa una moto se ho trovato della
marmellata fantastico se vado di sopra
visto che di sopra della roba strana c'è
della ci sono delle cose che cos'è sta
roba fatemi prima a buttare giù il vaso
poi tutto il resto bravo tremori crepa
dove va a terra perfetto non volevo
beccarsi qualcuno in testa sarebbe stato
bellissimo cioè non si insozza sulle
scale di ferro dove a guardarle premi il
tetano
insomma sul muro a caso però no no non
erano fermi no no no no no no no no no
vi era amico mio se more thing in culo
no no basta mi sono rotto tre quarti di
balle vai così maledizione vai che o
sennò ragazzino sul sul carrello ma io
sono un esperto pilota guardare niente o
la fetta di pane più potente della terra
potremmo fare la vita a fare sto livelli
non è un pò sorpreso la caramella
sarebbe bello ma è ovvio tostiano questa
le caramelle mi sembra giusto devo
andare cosa ci siamo ragazzi sono sopra
coming attimo che devo capire dove sto
no vabbè sono cascato [ __ ] si sono
sopra e adesso c'è un tasto vedi che va
a fuoco me faccio farla andare a fuoco
la gara non ho capito come si fa a farlo
andare a fuoco ma ok tanto su due
caramelle appiccicate addosso la band
perfetta dal c'è una bombola qua a don
buttar giù c'è questa questa da fuoco le
cose vai giù brava dai non riesca a
portare terminati se ho vinto ho vinto
la vita ho vinto tutto non vinto il
cassone successione di interruttore si
può premere in the seas sei serio non ci
non ci crederò mai nella veramente
contatti giocato non c'è mica stavo
cadendo si bravo bravo oddio no ragazzo
non sono gasatissimo vice non si posso
fottutamente credere
mamma ho vinto sta minkia è stato
bellissimo ragazzo all'avventura degna
di next ma c'è anche quello dopo
giardino c'è il giardino l'america
questo lo farà questo lo faccia vi prego
no per oggi basta non ne posso più
proprio bisogno ragazzi se avete bisogno
di pareto stato sapete dove cercarlo
perché tanto zio favi piuttosto a tutti
anche la mamma di qualcuno e quindi
ragazzi celebi non è piaciuto a società
lasciato commento mi piace anche a
paziente fast e book che come in ogni
video trovate nella descrizione
ricordatevi che ogni mi piace i video
sono un toast tostato in più cazzo sto
dicendo da ragazzi